abone ol
Az önce kendinden bahsedersen toz bu
kadar beni tanımıyor elisan seyrettiğini
başkenti çıkıyorum hemen zaten ondan
sonra Bilkent Üniversitesi'nde ulusal
çekmece akşam merkezinde 16'da yüksek
saat yaptı bağıran babam çalışmak için
koyuyoruz yaklaşık 10 yıla yakın
birleştireceğim bir program var
gökyüzündeki Türklerin faydalanabileceği
ve bayağı bakmıştım sonra size döndüm
başladığım nokta com com
da belki biraz daha farklı bir
perspektiften bakabilirim Hatta
sunumlarla bunu başlama belki de o bir
farkı için sonuçta Bazı şeyleri daha
görsel ve akla yanına yaklaşma istiyorum
İki kelimesinin kelime anlamı
gördüğünüzde parçalarını için hayat
gayesi Evet amaç anlamına gelir aslında
çok konuşan amacını indir gelebilecek
bir kelime alana sahip birogul
almaktadır Yani sizi Hatta gelecek
yönlendirmeye ehli iten duygular hisler
bulmanız Siz de sizin bunlarla barışık
olmanız ile ilgili bir oldum şimdi
buradaki dört tane kesişen kilo var
burada Ne anlatmaya çalışıyor ben
uzunlukları kırmak istiyorum buradaki
anlatmak istersen dört farklı şey bir
tanesi değil sevdiğiniz bir tanesini
nerede iyi olduğunuz diğeri yaptığınız
işten sen kazan
bu kendinize fayda sağlamanın diğeri de
sizin haricindeki gel dünya diyebiliriz
bu dünyanın değil cihaz oldu Şimdi
bunlar belli oranda kesiyorlar mesaj
diyelimki sizin iyi olduğunuz da
sevdiğiniz kesiştiği hızı tuttu ortaya
çıkıyor ama bu Eğer bu dünyanın ihtiyacı
olan bir şey değilse oturtma olarak
kalabiliyor ya da Bunlardan herhangi bir
ödeme alıyorsanız geçiyoruz buradan
sağlarsanız o hala olarak kalıyor bir
olduğu gibi kalıyor Ya da geleceğin
sizin sevdiğiniz de dünyanın ilk gelen
şey birleştiğinde 79 ortaya çıkıyor ya
da tam tersine kazancınızı sağlığımızı
ev şeyle dünyanın başka birleştirme
Sizin mesleğiniz ortaya çıkıyor Ve
benzedim Bir de uzmanlığı zor ne zaman
iyi oldun şeyle iyi olur şeyden Ödeme
alıp işimiz Ondan sonra başlarsınız
olarak uzmanlığı başı yalnız Burada şu
dikkat etmesi gereken şeyler var
hakların
bu metal Point ile göstereyim şu an
mesaj gönder Bak farkında bundan ev
burada mesaj şey bunlar özellikle
nelerdir Siz burada iyi olur Şöyle
diyorsunuz ama abla sevdiğiniz şey
yapıyorsunuz Ben onun için ödeme
istiyorsunuz ama bu dünyanın ihtiyacı
değil o zaman size bir fayda sızlık işe
yaramadı demiş oluşabilir Ya da sizin
yaptığınız şey beni hangi kazancımız yok
seviyorsunuz iyisiniz ve dünyanın
Peugeot Ama o zaman da bu size bir yani
Bebeğim bir kapat getirmeden özledim ya
biz içinde farklı şeyler bunların
hepsini birleşti ya Senin iyi olduğunu
söylediğiniz şeylere ihtiyaç oldu şey
birleşik dinlemesi Bunlar ayrıca kazanç
elde etmeye başladılar Tabii ki de
ortaya çıkaran ideal bir durumdan
bahsediyoruz Şimdi bu şey olabilir yani
budur tane göçmeni birleşimi aslında Çok
da gelse ideal bir durum ve her gün her
dakika Bunu yakalamak mümkün olmayabilir
ama zaten
O çocuğu da belki buraya giden bir pek
üzerine olmalı belki kr2di Ulaşılması
gereken günlük bir şey değil mi bir
yolculuk Benim oraya git vurması gereken
bir devlet gibi düşünebilirsiniz bundan
sonra bu saatten sonra ikiden ne olur Ne
olmadığını Aşık anladığımı düşünüyorum
onu Face'ye bakarsak bir kulaklık vurmak
istediğim şey şu şu olsun ben ya da
Eksen başarıp hesabı artan şekilde
dikerek Sen de kendini gerçekleştirme
aslında çok basit bir şey var burada git
başarılı olduğun şey de ayrıca kendisi
gerçekleşecek Yoksa yani bir tatmin
hissi oluşur Aslında bidattir özet
olarak yaparsak ya da tam ders başarısı
mısınız ve boşluk istediği ihtiyacı
içerisine Aslında o zaman daha Yakınız
Vestel Yani aslında karşı bulamamış çok
çabuk gibi bir şeyler farkı yok gibi
yani insan kendi ya sanki bu çarp
bu nereye koyduğunu annelik mesajla
bağlı olarak içine ile yolcu Belki bir
bağdaştırma yapabilir onu da demin
bahsettiğim şeyler Aslında gene dediğim
gibi burada özetleyiniz amacınız memnun
olmamız yani tatmin olmayan çekeceğiz
kendinizi gerçekleştirmeniz kendiniz
olmanız Ya da sizin dışındaki toplum
için sosyal biçimde anlamadi geldiğiniz
bakınız değerleriniz derlerse birleşince
iyiliğiniz ortaya çıkıyor Ve Bunların
aslında ortaya çıkması için şu dört özet
soruyu sorabiliriz hemen bu hayatta ne
yapmak istiyorum neleri Türk'ü yapıyor
yetenekleri neler yaşadığını ya katlara
Bunlar Şimdi ben kendi kendime Bu nasıl
araştırdım Sonuçta benim dediğim gibi
olsa yakın bir Amerikan deneyiminden
sonra e döndüm ülkemize ve Araştırma
grubu bakalım çalışmaya başladılar bu
Amerika'daki macerası çok oldu ben
girdikten sonra yüksek
bir süre bir Sonra hoca olayım ve
benzeri çok da net kafamda Aslında hala
ne yapmaya çalıştım arayabilirim sonra
yeni bir şeyler öğrendikçe bunun Ben de
bir dahaki oluşturduğu farketme çok
meraklı biraz interaktif burada sahip
birisi olduğum için sanırım dedim bana
böyle mesaj bir araba savaşları akşama
kadar evrak işleri üste memuriyet ya da
standart bir bir klasörleme istediği
kadar para kazanıyor Ben burada mutlu
ama aslında gibi Salih kazandığımızda
gider oluşmuyor Eğer burada bunların
bütünü mutlu olmanız kendinizi
gerçekleştirir hissetmeniz şimdi Ben
doktoraya başladım da bu kalp
Üniversitesi'ndeki bir teknisyen yap ya
Ben çalıştığım şey burada olmuştu
tartışmış Sen ne diyorsun o yapılabilir
diye beni resmen bolluk geliyorlar işte
ya bir şey sordu Benim bu sektörde 20
senden fazla tecrübem var Sen bunu
dönüşü olmaz bu Sağdaki benim doktor
olacağım doktora danışmalı ona git
Ben dedim ki bir uyduyu Sağdaki hocamız
be bu da Tom Tom gerekir Bu işi olmazmış
Ne diyorsun o da direkt onu yanlış
çıkardı Aslında doktor mu acaba böyle
başladı Yani mesela ben de bir resim
gönderdim bu çalışmaz dediğinde ben de
oluşmaya başladı markettir olması lazım
diye bir otomatik böreği çalışması nasıl
oluşmaya başladı Ben herkesi motivasyon
kaynağı farklı bir şey çözmeye
çalışırken orada hiç karşılaştım
sıkıntılardan bir yerden sonra zevk
almaya başladım hesabı alttaki şey nedir
peki bir önceki gibi Zoom görüntüsü
Amerika'daki Hoca ile ortak çalışma
yapıyoruz akademik makale yazma dört
buçuk saat geçmiş Ben buradayım Ya
normalde Mesela bir saat bir şey başına
bile otur sabah Ama bu da dört buçuk
saat geçmiş ve bu cumartesi akşamı
herkesin gideceğiz ip keyfbuk
rahatlamaya çalıştı bir anda ben
çalışıyorum ya
Şu an müsait değilim Mesaj bakarsanız
zaten müsaade çalışıyorsunuz mesai saati
bekliyorsun gitmez işini büyütmek için
zaten olmamıştır bulamazsınız dır
demektir diye düşünüyorum yani ben şey
Fikri vermeye çalışıyorum buldum diye
ideal hayatımı yaşıyorum ölüyormuş Bu
benim araya kalayım dedim arada buna
uzaklaşalım uzaklaştım bir durum bu
farklı oldu Ben Neredeyim ben Nerede
mutlu oluyorum zaman nerede kayboluyor
Benim iş bunlarda uğraşayım şimdi yasak
kendisini cevaplamaya Bu benim için
Akademi araştırma Bir Savaşın olabilir
sizin için başka bir şey olabilir Kimse
dünyayı gezerek mutlu basket kazanıyor
Yani diyeceğim bu aslında İnsanın
kendisini tanıması ancak cevap
verebileceği bir şey Ben sizin yerinize
şunu mesela dönelim böyle yaparsanız
Kimse kimse için değmez Çünkü herkesin
farklı herkes bak yerlerde
ve kendini gerçekleştirme potansiyeli
bunu da neyle tamamlıyoruz aslında şu
Sözde siz kalkıp bir Einstein içeri bir
kaldı bir bağı acıtır vermediğine göre
değişecektir yani sizin aslında herkes
dahidir herkes baslık kalabilir mi
fotoğrafı geri iyi oldu işler var ama
kimse bunu farketmez ömrünü geçirip
bitiyor Şimdi bunu 15 yaşına giriyor
Bence yapmak gereken insanın kendini
tanımaya çalışması topuk bir gün doğmaz
bir insan kendini tanıyamaz Ama bunun
üzerinde çalışıyor ben neredeyim ben
neden zevk alıyorum İşte bunların
hepsini bu dörtlü var baştaki sayıda
onların hepsi güneşin Aslında benim işte
Cumartesi akşam dörtlük saati
farketmedin gibi yaptığı işten zevk
almaya başlıyor ve bunu bu sonra orada
Şuradaki bir şey Devam oldu Kim şey daha
bahsedersen Aslında bu
ne olacağı belli bir şey varmış bir akış
5 Bu yatay Eksen kabul ettiğiniz dikey
eksende asla zorlar şimdi kabul
etmiyoruz az ve zorunda çok zor fazla
endişe ne durumdasınız ya bu istenen bir
durum değil tersine tabletle çok ama
zorluk yok çok kolay her şey yapabiliriz
o zaman da Can sıkıntısı başlıyor
Aslında iyi ya da denge Bu ikisi
arasında bir akışkanlığı diyeceğim yani
sizin alabileceğiniz de karşılaştığımız
zorluklara rengini esir öyle iş
yapıyorsunuz ki mesela abim denizde
orantılı zorluklar yaşıyoruz ve onu
oraya gideceğiz Biliyorsun yani Bir
Bakışı olduğu böyle zorlamayla belli
dışarıdan harici bir baskıyla bir olmadı
doğal bir akıp gitmiş bu Ben vardı Denge
ulaşmış bittikten gibi işlenir siteyi
topsolo gibi şeyler vardır bu insana
mutluluk veriyor zaten mutluluk verdi
ölçüleri insan ve Japon kültüründe ki
iki gel
o ulaşmış olduğunu düşünün Aslında beni
özetlemeye çalıştım tüm ülke Benim de
kendi yaşantımdan özet bilgiler de
benimki de hakkındaki görüşlerini
şekilde İnşallah herkes kendini
tanımayan zaman harcar ve ev bu yolda
kendim ne kadar erken tanı ve ona
gerekli olan şey ne kadar erken gelirse
son hayatlara iyi resmi o kadar erken ve
EFT bir şeyde kalır yapılacaklar
kalitesi de artacaktır diye düşünüyorum
benim sonra bu kadar arkadaşlar inşallah
faydalı olmuştur hepinize teşekkür
ederim dediniz